and for veronik and our chair we just
wanna see their love contain blossom
yeah I mean some parties going through
all of that drama a good father I think
chronic is being challenged to be like
to step up and a strong girlfriend and I
don't think she's really used to being
and those kinds of serious relationships
like especially because they just
started their relationship and all of a
sudden she's like helping him go through
something very traumatic and I think we
can tease that probably the sexiest
scene in riverdale history in an episode
a lot and it's between Betty I mean
doing it is high 15 it's very mellow
it's very um well something that I think
that is heating up is how making a
pussycat cuz they're looking fabulous
down there ladies
what has it meant to you three to be the
modern-day representation of such an
iconic group it's amazing it's such a
blessing to have three of us you know we
aren't the exact replicas and comic
books just in a book that's what it's
amazing to be able to show please have
talented Johson as lipping SR and bring
to life I love the food me in 2001 and
you know I don't show you guys talking
head but it may be be able to share with
you our love for the group and yeah I
feel like it's like honestly such a
journey itself love for all of us even
with just like wearing your natural hair
[Music]
like it's been so conversion and handle
blessing because it's not all the time
you get the opportunity to do that
especially on TV so we wrote out a long
I'll be there it's an amazing
opportunity
what type of neutral moment can the
expectancies into what well we need
something super iconic episode in this
you know don't you
we are literally singing the dopest song
ever I won't give it away but you got
everybody knows it like it's a glass are
you guys like flipping noses like under
the writers room being like just sing
discontent we just sing them on set all
day across all of ours
and actually are we going to be seeing
any more dynamics is Josie and his
family your mom's in there she's quite
powerful
I'm really hoping so I think we are
specifically with Josie and her mom I'd
like to see some more interaction with
Josie and her father I think that plays
a big part and who she is who she's
going to decide she wants to become so
yeah I'm really hoping that there's more
family yes there's just no we all love
robin givens who plays mayor Mikoyan
doesn't mind she's not incredible - we
have us we definitely big big stories
plan for her and Josie because they're
they're also going to be tested this
season and just real quick Veronica
these are often equipped editors can
even - I am John Estella pussycat yeah I
love that
um modeling you've burned down for till
he's one smelly girl where do you live
it
that's a solid particle all original
reveals and seasons oops oops I do have
a house somewhere sort of well in that
keep your trailer we saw a very chilling
scene what was it like playing that and
what can you tease about what share was
going to be going through with her
blossom family well Cheryl gets colder
and meaner and season two because of all
the things that happened in season one
but she takes the reins back from her
parents parents just the one picks
already cigarettes back and she starts
taking control of her life a lot more
which I think isn't a response for her
to do she needs five well and we've got
some babies on the way for the Cooper
and blossom families I don't know how do
you guys think this Cheryl and Betty are
going to be in Turkey I just think we're
gonna like have a lot of fun we have a
very interesting dynamic on the show and
to compare we yeah that we're going to
have that baby maybe I can tell you
we're horrible I also start which will
that actually leads me into my last
question before we go get actually vice
in the fans in the audience right now um
instead of the classic cliché that a lot
of other teen shows of the past of
pitting girls against each other it's so
nice to see that Riverdale has so many
beautiful female friendships and they're
genuine what does it like for you guys
to be able to have those relationships
on TV and be able to show that to the
girls out there episode 205 let me just
say is it a really big like girls
sticking together this mix st. Claire
guy the ex-boyfriend that comes into
town he's he don't work really bad thing
and it involves Veronica Carol
and because of that it's bring all of
the girls together it's kind of like
excited it's kind of in the same light
as episode theory in season one and
something that Roberto and I talked
about from the very beginning which is
that dynamic of girls fighting each
other it's just not interesting it feels
already played out and give them work
out for all the women on the shore very
different you know but they all find a
way to get along because afterwards
women in this world need to do and then
tonic I'm Cheryl who like obviously are
always going head to head they still
find a way to support each other which i
think is but you know deep down Cheryl
just really wants to be a part of the
game like oh yeah I got for my picture
though we're going to open up to you
guys in the audience right now I can't
really there you are oh wow hey what's
your name with your question hi I'm Zoe
and I'm from New Zealand no I was from
sorry for about Oakland is with KJ is a
New Zealand resident I was wondering if
the risk of the costumes is to picked up
any Kiwi play
oh my mints mints came from P King
fridge I want I had to change icon as
soon as I thought of wiggling these guys
this way to acknowledge me I had to
really cut down on the oh you don't
playing this family will it'll be a very
question hi I'm grace um my question is
for everyone
and if there's any trade from another
character that you'd like for a
character to have what are they also
penny your mystery animal into the
Italian oh I don't want to be as risk
Archie I think you have to make a
mineral first yeah I was pokin as Cheryl
I like these kindness okay what I love
to ROS confidence I do like Rhonda
confident oh my god I think Benny kind
of channels some of Cheryl inner demon
supports Iran's ability to eat another
buddy Kevin human watching like Casey
money we're not trying to have uh
Casey's perfect I kind of I you know
that's a good question maybe it's really
hard to add to that question no I I
think maybe a little bit of Cheryl
confident here she is and fearlessness
to burn down houses halogen and then
just every banter ah I think I would
find a little I was my minimal dark
everybody in like real dark prophecy
okay what's your name was devotion
hi I'm Paris and I was wondering who's
most likely or cares you're on the cat
let my heart I think y'all are y'all are
all very country well I'm or jogger
maybe I also not but either place
optative the neckline guys
my god and joy in the closet I think KJ
occasion he's just a thorium part of it
like that
clearly rattle may outgoing a message
very here
all right Anna pretty boy AJ is a
fearless leader I think of the show and
he done said every day always prepared
he's always encouraging having heart
even had that nothing said in the
outside is my style
I'll go that application kids on you all
we want up I also feel like our
Pussycats are most like their characters
because they're all so wickedly talented
yeah and what's your name on which is
uestion hi my name is Lauren and I was
in sorry my question is if you could be
any other character besides yourself who
would you be and why
I was a shy head which is quite burgers
oh oh oh dude how dude sixteen burgers
deep in the three takes not something
you want something like also like their
proper Gers okay the reason processor
but season one was like some
freeze-dried a w corruptive like the
krabby patty like the vegetarian patty
that looks like really rub under the
Chum Bucket
but how is it milkshake much better
they're actually way better they're
actual milk we have like real I'll shake
they were like yo they're Pedialyte er
no I'm sure besides being Jughead would
anyone else want stuff into anybody
else's shoes I would love to be Betty I
love fighting the vulnerability I think
it's beautiful she wears her heart on
her sleeve
I think that's really fun to fly it to I
think it'd be really fun to play Cheryl
you know in America yeah oh
what's your name which is pushing hi I'm
Jackie and I'm just wondering if any of
the actors had read the original comics
and if they took anything from those
characters what is their guru town of
course yes my mama had a huge box of
comics she still happen and she's had a
so she was a teen and I like that's on
them so I still have them a time yeah a
lot of us if except them yeah on the
pilot I like to read so many comics
because like that like they're probably
gonna like copy the storylines and
everything but I I think I think it
would want it would be really
inappropriate not to read any of the
comic play any characters so that should
be said but also we were given a
tremendous package of research materials
when we got the part I was not I knew
there's research on my right and I'm
still buying the come on what I mean but
yeah we the good thing is that arch arch
is been around for 75 years which gives
us as actors tremendous potential to
dive in and carry a character traits
that we want to fit into a show like
this so in in terms of being able to do
research we have the huge benefit of
having the largest source material that
we could for these characters which we
call use quite a bit
Roberto is the single biggest artist fan
like in the universe that story it's
funny every time we do a storyline in
Riverdale were like okay well that was
never done in the comic books coal or
someone he knows me a panel and it's
literally it's because there are
hundreds of thousands of story yes
so in someone last year sent me a
picture of like Archie kissing the old
miss Grundy in the comic book hi my name
is Charlie they tried so my question was
um and even one when Cheryl's underwater
and our shoes still breaking through the
ice
Cheryl music Jason as a zombie if
they're going to be anything else and
season two it's like supernatural like
that question good question terms there
that's a very very very good question
you know I love horse stuff and I love I
love you know dreams and jump scares and
things like that so we're always trying
to figure out ways to to put chains of
that in riverdale we have been talking
about one very prominent supernatural
character that exists in the art
universe and the way I'm going to cut
you up right now
that's how I could
[Applause]
you